une info qui a fait énormément parlé
c'est l'info du weekend c'est Matthieu
Orphelin le porte-parole de Yannick
Jadot je connaissais pas moi qui a été
écarté de la campagne présidentielle à
cause de sa proximité avec Nicolas Hulot
il dit 22h ce soir 1h avant que la
formation
donc le patron de
spécial
[Musique]
pardon c'est pas
c'est pas une question d'être c'est une
question que
l'entourage de le protéger
il fait
pour avoir une courage de témoigner qui
sont très grave et tu découvert en même
temps que tu
plus proche mais évidemment que je n'ai
jamais couvert de tel avis m'en
évidemment que je n'ai jamais été au
courant de tel agissements Nicolas Hulot
je le voyais comme quelqu'un qui a
effectivement été séducteur draguer on
l'a vu faire des dragues lourdes
je n'ai vu jamais évidemment ça aurait
tout changé de notre rapport à Nicolas
Hulot
c'est pour vous vous êtes obligé de le
mettre en retrait pour l'instant
il a mal pris
au moment de la sortie des Blue il a
parlé d'inquisition contre Hulot et en
fait il a pas fait son mea culpa de dire
mais j'ai pas cru les femmes ça donc je
pense que ça mérite un temps de
vérification de ce qui s'est passé c'est
tout c'était temporaire par son attitude
je pense qu'il a rendu le truc un peu
plus compliqué leur son retour dans la
campagne un peu plus compliqué mais
c'était temporaire et je pense que c'est
un tournant très important dans la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
parce que pour la première fois non
seulement les personnes qui sont visés
par les témoignages sont en
situation de démissionner mais en plus
elle est proche de me rendre compte du
fait qu'il est protégé ou pas et oui il
y a des protections